my name is Omarosa the cycle of july of
the native of sticks here in Davos we
are very busy discussing the new world I
listen to get for what mr. Paris have to
say mystical IV business first comment
and be with a woman and other issues us
should they go to prefer authority in
the commercial corporation for the
second point the clerk that which are
they are going to celebrate the 60th
anniversary I hope you and the Israelis
would remember that this case is also
the case of 60 years how about equality
continues and that the time has come for
all of us to cooperate see the build of
a new piece situation in our midst by
respecting the rights of the Palestinian
was stated their own quite nicely
distribution has its capital and a hope
that all of us would see a state of
Palestine that learn before the end of
this year in a court of gb pumps made
uncibal before he leaves reston bush
will make good his promise she will show
us that it is possible or this event in
administration to produce something that
will be lasting and its effects